yeah I mean there's so many different
ways to approach the problem with men
one is when you're looking at labor
force participation if you're looking at
prime age males you have a lot of folks
who don't have college educations who've
basically seen the labor market you know
their labor market position deteriorate
very very fast and the reaction has been
to withdraw from the conventional world
of work now you know what's the problem
with that well the big problem is when
you're not attached to the labor force
you also start losing your connection to
a lot of these basic bourgeois norms and
habits that are you know part of you
know life as a citizen in a free society
and then you're more inclined to engage
in pathological behaviors you're more
inclined to kind of have these masculine
impulses to provide and what have you
kind of corrode and manifest themselves
these really ugly forms so that I think
is what I think is the biggest and most
pressing problem that is particularly
pressing in the context of an economic
downturn like the one we're going
through
well I think that there are lots of big
structural changes that have happened in
the economy and they've been going on
for decades but now they're accelerating
by virtue of this downturn as happens in
any downturn and you know in broadest
sense it's this idea that you know
you're moving from a world that relies
on brawn to one that relies increasingly
on brainpower but beyond that it's also
a world that relies on certain kinds of
social intelligence on being able to
kind of construct networks that can be a
value to you that can enhance your
resilience in a rapidly changing economy
and again if you basically rely on your
strength in order to earn you an income
in a way that's not terribly specialized
in a way that requires you to take you
know direction but not necessarily even
have to take it very well that's just
gone and it's not only gone in the
United States it's gone in societies
like you know China and increasingly
India societies that we think of as you
know nipping at our heels but this kind
of large-scale dislocation is taking
place almost everywhere and then
societies in which it's not taking place
are being badly left behind in a lot of
other important respects I think if Iran
does a really good example of this as a
society in which men retain this kind of
very dominant position but at the cost
of economic stagnation
well I think on the global scale it's
more it's more interesting because it's
a lot sharper if you look at China for
example where you have this large
population of surplus males you're
talking about tens of millions of people
who could theoretically contribute to
chaotic violence to networked violence
gang violence etc if they don't find
some way of you know being stable
productive contributing members of the
broader society and I think that Iran
similarly is a society in which the kind
of taste for male dominance is such that
it will lead to entrenched poverty for
long periods of time you see this across
much of the world it's interesting the
extent which female literacy predicts
whether or not a society is going to
experience an economic take off there's
almost you know there's such a tight
correlation between these two things
it's quite remarkable similarly when you
look at domestic violence within a
society and how strongly that correlates
with how externally aggressive that
society is or the level of political
instability that society experiences
it's pretty interesting it again men
tend to be the perpetrators of domestic
violence when you're looking at the
United States you have this different
set of issues that we are already
dealing with and are trying to contain
through the instrument of the welfare
state so when we talk about prime age
males who aren't participating in the
labor force we're talking about guys who
are on disability benefits we're talking
about guys who are incarcerated a lot of
the time and the social consequences
that are unfortunately pretty obvious
and inner-city neighborhoods across the
country and pretty dire and you have
this issue you know you see now in the
african-american community but something
that's becoming much broader in which
women who have higher rates of
educational attainment have a very hard
time finding spouses and again this
complicates pretty much everything it
complicates the patterns of child
rearing it complicates whether or not
children have two biological parents in
the home and the knock-on consequences
of that relate to educational attainment
for the next generation so I think that
it really is part and parcel of a lot of
kind of big tangles of pathology that
we're dealing with not only an
inner-city it's not only with this or
that minority community but increasingly
across the entire American
halation